what's going on guys this is Rob and if
you're enjoying the content that I'm
uploading on my channel then feel free
to subscribe and you can also offer
suggestions on topics and characters and
storylines and whatnot that we can have
discussions on later on in this channel
okay so as we continue our discussions
on the hero Colin son of the Hulk our
journey actually takes us kind of that
to the fringe of things which is really
a little weird but this story actually
comes out as part of realm of kings now
for those of you guys who don't know
this is what's really kind of weird the
Marvel cosmology has always been this
weird situation where it's just got
always kind of been out there and no one
had really cohesively focused on it with
the exception of jim Starlin I mean he
was really the one that kind of
developed the cosmic opera to a degree
Infinity Gauntlet and infinity war
infinity per se at all that kind of
stuff I mean there were stories like
quasar you know there were stories like
Captain Marvel the dealt with cosmic
landscape to a degree quasar really
dealt more with the cosmic landscape
than anything else
but it was always just kind of out there
it wasn't really until annihilation came
along that Marvel and Dan Abnett and a
whole bunch of other people actually
started expanding on the Marvel
cosmology that's why annihilation is so
big
annihilation basically built it off from
the ground up and it actually works
really really well in addition to the
annihilation event there were a handful
of storylines there was you know
annihilation conquest there was a Thanos
imperative but there was also war of
Kings and realm of Kings now war of
kings dealt with blackbolt of the
Inhumans basically taking over the Kree
Empire and then going to war with Vulcan
the third Summers brother who had taken
over the Shiar Empire but what this did
is it allowed Marvel to be in the
process of streamlining things a little
bit trimming the fat on the cosmology
that they made and basically getting rid
of things that didn't work and keeping
things that did work but one of the one
of the incidents here was the creation
of the fault now the fault really played
more of a role in Thanos imperative when
we had like the cancer verse we had the
preceived death of like Richard Rider of
Thanos himself Peter quill was believed
to have died but he actually ended up
making it out but there were a handful
of things that ended up going on that
saw a lot of changes being made by way
of the creation of this fault but and
here I'll call his journey during realm
of Kings he basically comes along during
a fallout of war of kings and comes
across this fault now for him
observing the fault is really just kind
of like hey here is a rift in space and
time that leads to any number of other
multiverses other you know other
universes now the most notable universe
on the other side of the fault was the
cancer verse again we'll get into that
and we get into the Thanos imperative
because it's actually a really badass
story Thanos imperative pretty sweet
like it's pretty cool it's literally
like a giant cosmic war and it's like
everybody dies is it's pretty cool the
way it plays out but uh keep in mind
here you know he will call us on a
crusade to basically wipe out the old
power again the old power was created as
an answer as an equivalent to the power
cosmic of Galactus in order to basically
stave off Galactus whenever it was that
he showed up to consumer world the issue
with this was that once your Alcala you
know learned the truth of the old powers
creation he came to the decision that
the old power needed to be destroyed as
to what he did is he created a
combination of the power cosmic and the
old power he called it the new power and
he's now going on a campaign to wipe out
the old power everywhere he finds it now
the end game here for hero ecology and
result what he's looking to achieve is
to basically arrive on earth and to
destroy Skaar to destroy his father and
then eliminate the universe in its
entirety and the first step to doing
this is tantamount to what leads to the
destruction of the Microverse itself now
initially hero kala you know Axman bone
and action Beau's daughter don't really
know what's going on I mean for them
they're not super smart folks I mean
they were basically people who were on
Sekar when hero kala was there a hero
kala was a slave of action bone for a
while until he took the old power and
then he made accident about his
subordinate and then there was always
this kind of tease as to whether or not
you know the daughter of a VAX been bone
would end up becoming the wife of hero
Kali who was just something that was
kind of toyed around here and there but
in the midst of their journeys you know
while they were observing everything
suddenly hero kala is whisked away now
the reason why he was whisked away to
the Microverse and a truth I don't
really know why Scott Reed chose to
invoke the Microverse but the reason why
he was whisked away to the Microverse I
imagine has to do with basically Scott
Reed going back and retracing the most
significant moments of the incredible
Hawks life the reason why I say that is
there was a story where the Incredible
Hulk was basically taken to the
Microverse and he fell in love with a
woman named jerel ax but he also felt at
home because everybody on this planet
called Kai had green skin and so the
Hulk didn't really stand out like a sore
thumb the way he does on earth instead
they just saw him as a really strong
version of themselves because of this
the possibility of having a peaceful
life with Joella you know fostering a
family or just having a family and
basically living out his life in peace
was something that he couldn't avoid the
issue is that much like the Planet Hulk
storyline which came years after the
particular storyline where he was in the
Microverse you know it ended up with
gorillas basically being killed the
Incredible Hulk coming savage again and
realizing that his life was just going
to be one of lonely
and misery the kicker here is that at
the moment the planet Chi is currently
under attack by a group called the
Cyclops and the daughter I guess the
niece of gorilla had basically summoned
the Incredible Hulk under the belief
that because he had saved their planet
once before he could basically do it
again now the invoking of Cyclops here
is really a strange situation because
it's not Cyclops like as we know him as
part of the x-men a Cyclops was a
villain that goes back quite some time
and had a lot of dealings with the
Incredible Hulk but it was basically
just like an agent of the Dark Gods the
Dark Gods are one of these weird groups
of one of these weird pantheon of gods
and nobody ever really did anything with
uh but the idea was that the Cyclops had
it and had an affinity for the
Incredible Hulk under the belief that
because the Hulk had limitless strength
he had to have limitless power to go
with it and so Cyclops believe that if
he were to basically capture the
Incredible Hulk and use him as an energy
source he could engineer the Dark Gods
return the issue is that he was much
like a cat-and-mouse game where the
Incredible Hulk circumstances just put
him from one location to the next and
Cyclops would just chase after him all
the time until I got to the point where
the Incredible Hulk ended up in the
Microverse and the result was that
Cyclops was basically beaten to a pulp
The Incredible Hulk was pulled out and
Cyclops was just left there to die and
so because of this these these beings
that exists here these weird you know
organisms are basically what's left of
the Cyclops you know entity which is
currently invading chi now again a lot
of this is you know a lot of the
Microverse stuff is not really important
it's really just kind of Scott Reed
trying to bolster their Microverse
landscape but the Microverse was never a
huge deal I mean in truth this is one of
those instances where you have like a
pocket universe in the way this works
for those of you guys who don't know the
best example that I've been consistently
able to think of is to imagine the
Marvel Universe like a house and inside
that house you have bedrooms you have
closets different things like that you
know a bedroom would be like the
ultimate universe it would be like a big
universe the Microverse would be like a
closet where it's a universe within the
main Marvel Universe but it's more akin
to a dimension it's a very small place
but it has its own life he has its own
you know organisms and has planets and
you know galaxies and stars and so on so
forth it has its own thing it's just a
very very small version of the universe
those of you guys who saw the ant-man
movie the instance where Hank Pym was
basically telling Scott Lang if you
shrink down too far you'll just shrink
down into oblivion and truth he was
shrinking down to the point
he would enter the Microverse that's how
small it is and I'm sure Marvel will
introduce that in the movie line at some
point in time probably in phase 5 to be
honest but you know with regards to hero
kala being transported here he doesn't
quite know why he's here
but you know with him being as he is
effectively being a villain at this
point he basically lays waste to the
entirety of this Cyclops force but then
also essentially resurrects the spirits
of the people who were trapped inside
who had been captured now the reason why
he did this and even goes as far as to
saying is because by resurrecting them
he's also modified them to the point
that they are subservient to him they
are basically his inner guard this is
going to be a common theme because what
he's going to do is effectively enslave
the entirety of the planet but while he
had basically been whisked away we also
had Axman bone and his daughter driver
you know really just kind of flying into
the fault and trying to find a hero
collar which they weren't successful in
doing arriving on chi and along with you
know all the other bones men are really
kind of bolstered the ranks of hero kala
now at this point you know again he'll
call a sees himself as this kind of a
messiah you know as this godlike being
on a crusade to wipe out the old power
across really in any universe or any
dimension that he comes across the so
while he's here he also begins to come
to the realization that there is no old
power in the Microverse but there is a
source of power that rivals his own now
this is a slow build this is a slow
thing that Scott Reed builds here he
doesn't just jump into it right off the
bat but with it being a four-issue story
there's also the idea that things kind
of have to be relatively contained now
one of the things that he also does is
he basically says that much like The
Incredible Hulk uh you know hero kala is
not going to find true happiness and the
reason why is that while he's spending
time with Lyla the daughter of Axman
bone you know he kind of gets a glimpse
of what their future is going to be like
it even shows her to a degree and saying
you know here is the future that you see
the future you see is us being together
ki and Queen he says the future that's
going to be is basically meaning going
through and just wiping out everything
that I come across literally becoming a
force of nature and laying waste to the
universe itself and he says I am
destined to be this way because of the
fact that my father is the Incredible
Hulk and my brother is scar my family
line is a genealogy of rage and anger
now of course Lyla responds by saying no
no no no you're not bound to by your
genes and there's a legitimate claim to
this I mean there's there's legitimacy
and saying that he's not bound to this
life that he's that he feels he's doomed
to leave but in here
kalla he solidified his fate without
ever giving it a second chance whether
they were actually sitting down and
saying is it possible for me to live a
happy life he's basically said I am
doomed to a life of death and
destruction because that's just what
I've chosen for myself now what he also
does is he gives Lila and otter and on
an artifact that called the the enigma
force nullifier now the enigma force
nullifier is exactly what it sounds like
but it kind of requires us to talk about
the enigma force so the enigma force is
really in an emag matic force I mean
almost no one knows anything about it
and Marvel never bothered to explain it
probably just living up to its namesake
the Enigma force but it's effectively
this force of energy now within the
Microverse it's equivalent to the power
cosmic it is the end-all-be-all force
you know anybody who wields it has
absolute power they can literally do
whatever they want to and reshape
reality as they see fit
outside of the Microverse the enigma
force is basically just a force of
energy that a person absorbs and they
become captain universe for time so it's
really kind of a weird situation in
terms of how it relates to people but
again while all this is going on you
know while hero kala is being viewed as
a god by the citizens of KY due to the
fact that he casts off their invaders
and resurrected the souls of people who
were believed to have been dead but Jets
hora is basically watching these events
unfold now keep in mind gen tours the
girl that brought him here she's the one
that teleported him here with the
intention of teleporting The Incredible
Hulk
now Scott Reed doesn't tell us why Scott
Reed does not say here is why hero kala
was teleported instead of the Incredible
Hulk
all he really says is gen tour wanted to
teleport the Incredible Hulk to their
planet but hero kala arrived instead
maybe it was just proximity you know
maybe it was just you know for whatever
reason but he was just the one who was
there keep in mind this is also during
the time where Bruce Banner cannot
become the Incredible Hulk this is prior
to the events of a fall of the Hulk's
and world war hulk so the reason why I
chose to do this though is because of
self contained it has nothing to do with
follow folks and world war hoax it never
ties into it it's just kind of out there
in left field but it but chronologically
and I'll actually make sure this falls
in the chronology of the the playlist
for the Incredible Hulk chronologically
this comes before fall of the hoax in
world war hulk so at this moment Bruce
Banner cannot transform into the Hulk
but the fact remains here that you know
as hero kala is going through because of
the fact that he has this power cosmic
slash you know Oh power while it doesn't
really allow him to do a lot of things
in in the Microverse it doesn't
him too since you know energy on a
better level then other people would
normally be able to detect and this is
when he comes to the realization of what
the enigma force is and the power that
the enigma force possesses he basically
says it rivals my own abilities and he
says this force of energy can be used by
me to basically you know cast off and
destroy the the old power everywhere I
find it essentially saying I can use
this to bolster my own abilities now
again during this time we also have a
guy by the name of Arcturus Tran now our
Taurus Tran has been a longtime member
of the Microverse he was really kind of
like this star Lord of the Microverse so
to speak where he was basically an
adventurer more so than anything else he
had his own stories his own origin I'm
not gonna go into that because he's not
even remotely relevant in any form of
fashion if he comes up with the movies I
guess I'll make a video on it but that I
have no reason to believe anybody would
care about a video on Arcturus rant but
the idea here is that our Taurus ran was
a guy who's basically imbued with the
enigma force he can do a lot of
different things it had been dormant for
quite some time but he's effectively in
a lot of ways God in the Microverse if
he chooses to use the enigma force to
its full to his full fruition the issue
with this was that he basically
developed cancer over the course of his
life and the idea was that the enigma
force was at fault and so really the the
main baseline behind his adventures as a
character in the Microverse comics was
to effectively track down the enigma
force nullifier and do exactly what it
sounds like
nullify the enigma force and cure his
cancer the issue at this was that
because of the fact that the the enigma
force nullifier was something of myth
and legend a lot of myths and a lot of
legends had surrounded it and so people
had this perception or this belief that
the enigma force nullifier was created
for the purpose of not really knowing
the enigma force instead it was a
misnomer the enigma force nullifier was
created for the purpose of nullifying
the power of people who could threaten
the entirety of the Microverse and who
were too much of a challenge for the
enigma force to deal with and so because
of this our tourists ran basically you
know Ria's with the full totality of the
enigma force and comes to fight hero
kala now the crazy thing about this is
he basically says we're going to
activate the enigma force nullifier
we're going to set this in motion and
we're basically going to wipe out the
entirety of the of the the Microverse
and reset its history which would
effectively mean that hero kala was
never here it was basically a way to
just kind of wipe heroic challah out of
existence and that's the way
different universes of work that's kind
of how they come into existence in
Marvel Comics when it comes to a person
being transported to other universes
it's not like your consciousness is
transported to another universe there
are times where that's the case but for
the most part whatever people go to
another universe their entire physical
being physical spiritual being goes to
that universe and so if they're in a
universe that ends up being totally
obliterated they will die with it and
they will cease to be and nobody from
their home universe will have any idea
what happened to them and so with like
hero kala for example assuming there was
anybody out there that care that he
existed if you were to die if he were to
perish with the destruction of the
Microverse
he would just cease to exist nobody in
the main Marvel Universe wouldn't know
where it was that he went to they
wouldn't know what had happened to him
so it would be like if you moved he
would just be gone one day and people
would just be like well that's weird
and they probably would really think too
much about it with regards to hero kala
because again he's just kind of a dick
and has just made enemies out of
everybody that he's come across but the
fact remains here that our torus Tran is
able to put up a very notable fight
against hero ecologist because of the
fact that you know he has the full might
of the enigma force behind him but keep
in mind here hero kala is not entirely
powerless while he's not necessarily on
par with the enigma force in its full
might he does still have the ability to
control the tectonic plates of Chi he
does still have the ability to
restructure his own physical body so
long as he's touching the ground when
he's damaged and that's exactly what
happens River the old power allows
people to manipulate the very ground
they stand on but those individuals who
are tied directly into the old power
effectively have bodies made of rock and
so hero kala can restructure his own
body and any former fashion as long as
again he's touching the ground so he can
regrow a limb you know he can basically
rebuild himself and that's what he does
here you know while actress Tran is
tearing him apart it's also this
realization that everything is going to
come crashing down that everything is
gonna come to an end because with this
enigma force nullifier being created
it's like this annihilation wave if you
know this is this nullifier wave just
sweeping across the Microverse to the
point that it's basically going to reset
the entire history now this is basically
a way for Marvel to kind of come back
and reboot the history of the Microverse
the issue with this is that nobody ever
really cared about the Microverse nobody
was racing to a comic book store to buy
Microverse number one or micronauts
number one no nobody was doing that it
was a niche
like that just never really perform very
well but it was kind of a cool story in
and of itself in the sense that with a
belief that hero kala would be wiped out
what is up happening is that the truth
of his power is revealed here in the
sense that yes it's a micro verse yes he
is very capable but where we as the
reader up to this point would believe
that his power was reduced in fact it
was not that hero kala was just as
powerful in the in the Microverse as he
was in the regular universes so because
of this worthy where the wave goes
through and just resets the history of
almost everything hero kala is not
impacted in any former fashion we have
of course our tourists ran and his and
his team essentially just kind of you
know trying to trying to keep themselves
safe and reverting back to their ship
the but in the end you know we have a
hero Colin surviving the entire
encounter and so what he does is he
basically grabs the planet of Kai and he
removes it from the Microverse he
literally takes the planet out of a
universe and brings it to the main
Marvel Universe and what he's going to
do is he's basically going to use this
planet to invade the planet Earth he's
going to use it to launch his campaign
against Skaar and against the Incredible
Hulk in an attempt to kill his brother
and Achilles father and then go on to
basically wipe out all things in
existence across the universe but with
that being said if you guys are new here
to comics explain and you guys want to
see some more of the of incredible ops
stuff make sure you guys hit the
subscribe button make sure you guys
leave a comment and drop a like because
hero Carlos got kind of a weird story
but fortunately for us this is about as
far out in left-field as we get you know
Scott Reed kind of gets lost out there
in the weeds but he ends up being a
realing himself back in and we kind of
get back to to normal circumstances we
get back to things within reason or at
least as in reason as you can be when it
comes to some guys that possesses a
combination of the old power the power
cosmic in the Enigma forest and wants to
wipe out all things in existence but
with that being said guys we're going to
bring this video to an end and I will
catch you all later peace
[Music]